[Music]
there's a strange phenomenon going
around
in politics today which is that if you
look at the
extreme left like the woke left and you
look
at you know the four like white
supremacists
left in america you know i guess what
you would call the extreme right even
though some people quibble about that
when you listen to them talk they sound
eerily similar you may even have seen
this video
going around the internet recently from
the comedian ryan long
it's like he's a mind reader i mean i've
been pushing for segregation forever and
my man does what
i created an improv comedy show
exclusively for ethnic people that
segregates comedy on my birthday white
people need to stop wearing dreadlocks
and then
stop appropriating black people's music
shaved heads in country music the way
god intended
you know all white people are racist i'm
listening
so it goes on you should go check out
the entire video
well we've got that man who put out that
video and lots of other really funny
content
ryan long a comedian and filmmaker from
america's hat toronto canada but he now
lives
in new york city amid all the crazy
lockdowns
you may have seen him on netflix nbc mtv
fuse tv
the score but nobody watches any of
those like legacy channels anymore
probably you've seen him on his youtube
channel or you've listened to his
podcast
the boys cast with ryan long ryan thank
you for being here
hey buddy thanks for having me dude i
love your stuff
i think it's extremely funny and the the
thing that shocks me most about it
is i don't understand with the way that
you have poked fun
well you know also at the right but
especially at the left how you've not
been canceled yet why are you still
around why are you not cancelled
dude there's a there was like a bunch of
people on the internet every time i open
my phone right now it's a bunch of
people yelling at each other and yelling
at me this is the virtual rage
the virtual rage room of twitter so
people no
definitely people have gotten canceled
but uh tried to cancel me but one of the
funny things is people like me that
aren't in the industry anymore and i'm
kind of doing my own thing and they
so now they're kind of like canceling
each other because they go oh we're
going to take your job away and you go
what jobs like what are you taking away
my
rrs my rss feed so i'm not in that game
anymore so a lot of people like me are
doing our own thing because the industry
stinks right now well it's funny you
mentioned that because you know i was i
was only half joking when i said i don't
care about nbc
mtv like none of that really interests
you you're right though it's like your
[ __ ]
your youtube channel is way more
interesting to me
and the same goes for a lot of other
comedian friends
that's much more interesting than
getting some network tv co-star or
something like that
dude those networks right now are
basically going to everyone in america
and they're saying this is what you like
now and everyone's like no it's not what
are you talking about
like if i take the crazy pills and
they're like here's your new favorite
comedian and everyone's like what this
guy is
you know they they used to do this in
old hollywood you'd see it'd be like
your next movie star is going to be
johnny smith you know they'd go to some
small town and find some random guy
and foist him on you and that that
doesn't seem to work anymore
no the the probably the most recent one
of those was john krasinski after the
office there was like 95 movies where
they're like huh john from jim from the
office and everyone's like
i mean i guess he's okay i guess if i
have to i guess i'll watch it
you know on the on the point of being
canceled for politics
your videos have gone viral especially
because you've dinged the
left but you've also dinged the right
too you know it's not like
you're you're kind of cutting both ways
here yeah yeah i think i'm like con
a lot of times i'm just digging like
dogmatic thinking and i'm not even
necessarily saying anything about the
ideology as much as like the people who
make it their entire identity and try to
push it on everyone else yeah i mean
would would you
would you consider yourself a
conservative or you're kind of just
you're a comedian you're kind of outside
of politics
or partisan politics generally yeah
that's what i'd like to think of it i
kind of like to think of it if
there was two people fighting over who's
going to be the teacher and i'm the kid
at the back of the class sort of making
fun of it
but people so when you say that people
always go so you're a centrist i go no
i'm not playing the game
you're not part of the game and and that
used to be okay to be completely honest
it didn't you know and that's obviously
something that's you know way worse on
the woke left where
they want your they want your political
identity to be like your entire part of
your personality it used to be like
you know oh this guy he's into football
and he did this now it's like oh so and
so
he's a liberal or he's a conservative
and you know everyone has their leanings
but that didn't used to have to be like
the entire thing that defines you and
who you hang out with and who you date
and what shows you watch
so that's one of the parts that's extra
crazy right now that used to be
the idea of the artist actually going
back to a a medieval comedy going back
to like dante who wrote the divine
comedy he has this is his famous
yeah there's a famous line in the in the
poem where he says
i i left partisan politics you know i'm
going to be a party of
one and he used to think of comedians as
like yeah he's a party of one you know
he's going to dig into these guys
he's going to dig into these guys he's
going to show these absurdities
but i noticed the criticism of you
is not coming from the right it's only
coming from one side of the political
aisle right now
yeah i even said that 99 of the people
that were mad at my video work in
entertainment or the media
normal people don't care well it's kind
of like
the the woke left you know they kind of
run hollywood and they're the
predominant power
right now right it's kind of like if you
think of them as so they're
they're always kicking people out right
they're you're not allowed in our club
and the right and far as media goes
they're always like
you come over here come on the water's
warm come on in here right
and they kind of say hey the so it's the
right everyone's trying to push you to
the right regardless of what your
ideology is
but one of the reasons that you want to
stay i i personally want to stay away
from
even like planting a flag down is
because i mean you've probably been
alive long enough
to see those two words change so much in
such a short period of time so when you
start saying i'm a this
and then six months later they can tell
you oh remember that thing you are it
means something completely different now
and you think this now and you think
this now and you go you know what i'm
just not going to take a label if you're
going to change them every 15 minutes
and i have to like update what i think
of course it's so much easier you know
rather than having to keep up with
whatever the latest thing is changing
out it seems like it changes hourly
instead you can just what do we do right
now yeah who do we hate
who are we gonna we're gonna tar and
feather out of here well you know on
that
on that point of like the industry tar
and feathering people
i remember when adam corolla started his
podcast he called it
the pirate ship and he said i'm not
gonna be beholden to hollywood i'm gonna
be in a pirate ship
and he said okay that's nice you're in
your own little area but all the big
money
all the big shows that that's all in
mainstream hollywood
now i look at all the biggest shows i
look guys like joe rogan for instance
right joe rogan is
a zillion times bigger than virtually
anybody who works in mainstream
hollywood
do you see do you see hollywood getting
its
kind of mainstream power back or is this
is this
isolated you know go your own way do
your own channel
is that the future of entertainment yeah
and it's not just
i mean they lost control of the press
tour like you were saying like you used
to be you have a movie and you go okay
we'll put you on this show this show
this show now it's like
if you want to do that you call joe
rogan and if if he feels like it
you don't have control of him so yeah
you're right i mean it's so crazy
to watch that happen but it's not just
hollywood i mean
it's the it's uh the universities it's
you know this virus has gone everywhere
right yeah
so the amount of people that just work
at some company and they're getting
their stuff shoved down their throat
every second
so it's so pervasive it's hard to and
there's this loop of
you know advertisers needing to be woke
them making woke content
because if you say oh we're going to do
this edgy show your advertisers are like
well we want the no trump show you know
so it's someone would have to like clear
out the whole regime of you know 20
you know 20 year old girl opinions if
they if they wanted to
actually say we're going to make south
park again or something like that right
so i think it's a complicated scenario
but it sounds like
this is gonna happen and they're gonna
probably like they do with everything
else like they're doing with podcasting
they get into the game late
and they're gonna just have to drop
boatloads of cash at people's houses if
they want to get back in the game
five years later yeah well speaking of
20 20-something-year-old girl opinions
it was actually the way i first
found you is my wife who you know is a
little more reasonable than most 20
something year old girls
but my wife my wife said you got to
watch this guy this guy's really funny
and my first reaction was okay it's
going to be one of these
like how many times do you hear oh you
got to watch this funny video on the
internet and but the guy
isn't he's not a comedian he's like just
a guy who did a funny thing on the
internet one time
you think okay whatever but the thing
that strikes me about you
is you're not just a guy who did a funny
thing on the internet you are an actual
comedian
and there is a huge difference here you
know between just some kind of hobbyist
and
an actual pro from your advantage within
the
the comedy world the pro real comedy
world
what is the consensus here now i mean
what what is
funny what is what are people who
actually
make people laugh for a living what are
they going toward
well that's why like doing comedy clubs
for the last 10 years three times a
night
you know actually finding out what real
people think instead of what these
people do where they design what they
think they should think
and then work backwards they're like
well we know what we want them to think
let's move backwards from there we'll
design everything backwards from the
ideology of like where we'd like it to
end up
whereas you know i've always been like
sort of a counter culture guy and a punk
guy like i know
if i went out there and i was i said
trump's a loser and i could see people
like kind of being like
all right yeah like i hear that i could
i could turn on my tv and have people
yell at me all day you know if i want
if i want to listen to if i want to get
yelled at by a comedian i can listen to
stephen colbert
so i mean for me it's i've always kind
of been into
actual counterculture and kind of
speaking uh against what the mainstream
ideology is and what the viewpoints that
i feel like are shoved down my throat
and what we're forced to lie about yeah
but doesn't mean everyone has to do that
i mean depends on your sensibilities
right like a lot of comedians just want
to go up there and
make jokes about uber but the problem is
those comedians that used to be
hey i'm going to make jokes about coffee
and uber the world's like also you have
to be into politics now and they're like
uh i don't know i guess trump's bad
because they're not equipped for that
fight
right right i think even like seinfeld
said they said why don't you make trump
jokes
and he said i want to make jokes about
strawberry pie like i don't that is not
what i
what i want to do i like this idea of
the the john krasinski effect
that that you know hollywood these these
opinion makers are saying look
this is what you have to like this is
what's going to be really funny and
you're going to go to the movies and
watch it
it's it's what they did to us in 2016
right they said yeah
that you know what people really want is
hillary clinton
you're like are you uh are you listening
to yourself right now or frankly even in
2020 they say
you know what the youths want with the
kids they want joe biden
the people are crying out and you just
think like you are so
disconnected from reality that a a
reality tv
star media mogul who's probably never
read two books about politics
is much more in line with what the
average common common american is
thinking
than any of the people you're putting up
oh 100
and then on top of that they use like
dirty tricks like racial guilt and stuff
to try to
you know force you into those things
like they you know that's the stuff i
talk about
and the thing they go if you're not
black if you're black and you don't vote
this way you lose your black
card you see them saying that i was like
what kind of cold stuff what are you
everyone's like what are you talking
about
yeah you know oh so i'm black guy this
is the list of opinions i gotta have or
i'm a trait like what are you talking
about
so i think there's a lot of that stuff
going on and
they are in a big way missing it but so
people say there's not good comedy
there's lots of really good comedy i
have a lot of friends that are
making a lot of good stuff the industry
just needs to catch up in a big way
well i also noticed this thing which is
yeah now they're saying if you don't
vote a certain way if you don't you know
you're
you're a traitor to your race you're a
nazi you can be a black white
supremacist now
you can be a jewish neo-nazi now and
they i guess they don't even hear what
they're saying
but there's this weird effect that's
going on which is
the more and more that people move away
from doing what they tell them to do
the the louder and shriller and more
desperate
these opinion makers seem to get you
know is that
is that a sign of of them losing their
grip of power or is it a sign that
they're
about to clamp down no it's it's
definitely a sign that they've already
i mean they've already lost their grip
of power but they still own the
institutions
i mean they've lost the control of
people's minds a long time you know
years ago
this coveted stuff has started to flip
you know back up again
but it basically feels like you're a
company
and instead of being like hey uh our red
shirts are selling
by the millions let's uh let's sell more
of those and they go up production on
red and you're like why it's like we
just think that red's better for the
people
so they're just and you go what they
don't want that what are you talking
about
i was reading uh another reason like a
lot of my friends are so sick of this
stuff whatever color they are
like you know most of my friends it's
like we're just comedians no one but you
know that's how we consider ourselves
right
but they go there was this big article
that was kind of going viral and was
like why black guys need to
talk about their male privilege or
whatever right and it was just all the
same stuff it was like
did you like white privilege well here's
blackbird from the guys that brought you
from the creators of male privilege now
here's blackmail privilege
all of the guilt of male privilege but
repurposed for black men
and you're like and you and you think a
black guy wants to read this and be like
i'm in
yeah i love it yeah no one likes this
stuff
shut up yeah there's like an infomercial
but but wait there's more
not only do you get your white privilege
but you also get your black privilege
you know i was watching this hearing
talk about comedy gold i was watching
this hearing the other day
of all of these democratic politicians
including eric swalwell
my absolute favorite grilling the
attorney general bill barr
and so all of these democrats are
grilling bar and
they say well hey do you think that if
we just have
completely widespread mail-in ballots
with
no structures in place to collect them
and no accountability do you think there
could be interference in the election
and bars says uh yeah i think probably
there could
and and the lady goes well do you have
any evidence do you have any scientific
studies do you have any proof of that
he goes uh no i have common sense i i
guess this is in short supply now
but i i guess common sense to me is
kind of the the prerequisite for comedy
and it
it would seem to me kind of why the
company is moving a little bit more to
the right
yeah i mean it's it's it's definitely
there's a situation where
your average person finds themself
leaning towards the right because they
just they go
because this left basically says you
need to be on either side
yeah and then normal people go all right
well i know i'm not that
yeah i mean you know because especially
most people
especially you know i'm from canada and
toronto right so it's like you know you
kind of grow up in a liberal
metropolitan you sort of you know for
the most part only hear one side right
and that just became the sort of so you
kind of you never really paid that much
attention to what you know maybe you
kind of get into libertarians some
people kind of become libertarians or
whatever right
but you know all you were told was like
that's the bad thing and they go
well you gotta have a sign you i just
don't wanna be part of this and they go
well you have to and then you start
being like
i guess the other side then i don't know
but that's why it's funny for
for comedy especially because they go
your art supposed to have a message
right which they mean you know and
you're like yeah the christian church
also thinks that my art should be
propaganda for a movement
but what they really mean is your art
should say my message and i'm like
because if they go art's got to have a
message and you go okay my art's the
trump's awesome and you're like
okay well it can't be that you don't
whatever it you know
i was talking to adam corolla the other
day and
adam and i disagree on many pretty
foundational political issues
like we actually you wouldn't if you
were to construct a political party you
wouldn't
look at all the people and say like yeah
those two guys are going to be on the
same side
and so adam has been asked are you a
conservative and he's like he's like
here's what happened
one time i said that that parents should
feed their children lunch
i was asked about like a school lunch
issue and i said yeah parents
should make a ham sandwich for their
kids
and then the left got so angry at me
that i guess
that makes me a conservative so that's
what i am i'm a i'm a feed your kids
conservative who knows but i guess
that's kind of the box that people are
being pushed into now
yeah i think you know it comes down to
the
the i the truth is you know the way
america is designed
you know where you have the
conservatives they're kind of the dad
and the liberals that are kind of the
mom
and it's like no one wants to be
tyrannically run by either of them
but you know one seems a little crazy
right now so you know a lot of times
the pushback isn't that bad and me
personally i'm like would be more of a
freedom versus safety person personally
you know and i don't necessarily need to
like impose the way that i think on
everyone
but that's one of the reasons i moved to
america instead of canada because
you know i'm like you know i think that
freedom and liberty are important and
individualism and stuff like that but if
you get to a scenario where they go one
of these
gangs is going to rule over you and
and then all of a sudden you're fighting
it's like in anything
all of the fights between people happen
like the truth is everyone wants to say
that everyone argues and
these racial groups hate each other
truth is everyone gets along pretty well
until you say we're going to pick one of
us and everyone else has to live that
way
you know as long as people get to live
their own life the way they want to we
all get along pretty well when we're not
being imposed each other's beliefs on
each other and i like this idea of the
left as the mom
you know but it's like that not even not
like the most nurturing mom in the world
like kind of a little more of an
overbearing mom i just did you see this
thing that was going around on instagram
where women were posting
like black and white hot photos of
themselves
and with the hashtag challenge accepted
like it was like a challenge you know to
post a selfie on instagram
that's that to me that's that's the way
that the mom is the left right now it's
like the mom
posting the selfies saying that they're
really brave and stunning
and beautiful yeah and they're the mo
there's also the mom that's like telling
you
that uh you need to wear a skateboard
helmet if you're gonna you know just
skateboard on the driveway yeah but then
they're also like more importantly all
your friends need to wear them and if
your friends don't have them i don't
want you hanging around those kids
anymore yeah i don't like johnny you
stay away from johnny and
because johnny had a tweet two years ago
yeah yeah he's gonna tell you some
he's gonna tell you simpson's quotes
[Laughter]
so that's this is my worry for comedy
though is like your stuff's great
you know a lot of actually not a lot but
a number of other guys are putting out
great stuff these days yeah but you know
christopher hitchens when he once said
that women aren't funny
he made this distinction between being
funny
and having a sense of humor and those
are those are two different things right
to be funny you make people laugh to
have a sense of humor
you understand comedy and you laugh
yourself and you can
you can laugh period are we in a
kind of dangerous situation here in
comedy because i noticed
there are still funny people but like
half the country maybe
and it's not totally along ideological
lines but it's pretty
close it seems to me we haven't lost our
ability to be funny we've lost our
ability
to have a sense of humor and to
understand comedy which seems necessary
for comedy to thrive i love how you uh
squeaked in that women aren't funny and
that analogy
wasn't even that relevant okay see you
later
i always say with the women that that
christopher virgin thing i know i know
what he's trying to say a little bit but
stand-up comedy it's almost more so that
stand-up comedy is a masculine art form
and more men
want to do it yeah so you kind of
there's there's a lot at play why
there's more men
you know the one of the it's just like
anything it's like it's not just one
thing
but i know a ton of girls that are
hilarious it's just sometimes going in
front of a room full of people
and yelling at like that's a masculine
art form to begin with whether whether
girl or guy well it's funny
that's kind of the point hitchins was
making is like people totally
misunderstood his point which
his point actually wasn't the headline
women aren't funny his point was
stand-up comedy tends to be a more
masculine art form so he gave examples
of women who are funny but
yeah there's tons of girls that are i
mean i'm i have lots of friends that are
like super funny
of course that does get misinterpreted
and weaponized sometimes
and i'm probably part of it i do have
podcasts called the boys guys and i'm
like women suck
sometimes they're like god that's like
that's not what i meant though
i just i just think that guys are all
girls are always like girl power i'm
like how about dudes rule that's my new
movement you're not invited
it's so brave stunning and brave in
terms of yeah yeah in terms of the
most people because stand-ups comedy
should be
especially especially in a live setting
is a you make
jokes that you think are funny and then
your conscience allows you to make like
you feel you know what that was the
right joke the same way that when you're
with your friends
you make fun of each other but there
might be a time where you go uh you know
what
i he didn't even blow up but i kind of
felt bad when i said that that felt over
the line so you have your own conscience
of what you
think it makes sense and then the
audience has gets to vote on whether
they like it with their one vote they're
laughter
the problem is other people that weren't
there now
think they get to vote they get to like
watch it afterwards and be like that was
wrong and you go
well there was a democratic vote in that
audience on laughter and the vote was
they liked it
and you go well they're wrong they're
stupid
those people are stupid and they're
racist and you what about the black guy
he hates himself
and that's what these people are doing
but most people for the most part
actually aren't that crazy but they're
afraid but if you're good at comedy
and you know it is tough to do but if
you're good at comedy
you can make people uh feel comfortable
and you're like hey guys we're gonna
laugh at everything right now and
it does it's not because we're bad
people it's because we're fun people
that's a great point i haven't seen
before that that
similarity between comedy and politics
which is that
it's all about the circumstances right
it's all about the context
i mean like it's actually the example
you use is direct which is
there's a democratic vote in the comedy
club if they laugh
it worked if they don't laugh it didn't
work there's a democratic vote in
politics you know if you get elected
then you've said something that
resonates with people
and that might change over time
something that's funny 30 years ago
might not be funny today some politician
who got elected 30 years ago
might not get elected today but how
insane is it to go
back and say yeah you told a joke 15
years ago and now
i don't like it and you're dead and i'm
going to ruin you and ruin your life
yeah because the context is different
right because you know
it's a lot of times you're not with the
comedy you're not even
so much people talk about it being like
a truth-telling art form but it's
it's not about so sometimes it's not so
much about telling the truth
as much as being not forced to tell lies
because it's more like everyone's it's
like if uh you know sometimes you'll see
it in
in you know the body positivity movement
with women or whatever they'll go this
girl's so beautiful and you go all right
whatever like you join me and they're
like
no but say it though you have to say it
you have to believe it yeah
and you go okay i don't care if you want
to say that and think that
but when you need me to now say it
that's what's becoming a problem
so it's like if you want to go like your
thing that you like fine
but when you need to go no but you need
to say it's good and i think that's like
a lot of times what it's pushing back
against
because the context is different i
wouldn't i'm not like a need to tell the
truth if i'm with
someone that's you know that person
let's say a two out of ten girl
i don't i don't like hey you're gross
because i'm a truth teller and i need to
say this
that's not how i feel yeah but if ten
people are in my face being like
tell her she's beautiful i then i might
be like well she's not though no
stop making me beyond i don't want to be
honest i don't want to say anything but
yeah i mean it's i mentioned it earlier
now it's become a kind of cliche is this
idea of stunning and brave you know that
basically
there's this kind of i don't know
politically correct orthodoxy
that makes you say i guess it started
really with with caitlyn jenner
is you say okay bruce jenner wants to go
by caitlyn jenner now all right it
doesn't really bother
me it doesn't you know no big deal i
have other things that i think about
but it's when you're told that you have
to
say this what this woman is stunning and
brave yeah i mean even
i think nor macdonald had a bid on this
he's like look you know they want me to
say that she's brave and beautiful and
uh maybe she's brave but
like how many 60 something year old
women do you know who are like
really really hot uh not too many uh you
know yeah
in their own way but but not not too
many yeah that's it's just a culture of
lies that's being
being voiced in on people and that kind
of makes you react
yeah and people are like over it you
know so when you give them the
permission
to not uh say that because a lot of
times uh you know comedy can be like a
pressure release valve right
because there's so much of uh people
feel like they're being gaslip right
it's kind of
so sometimes it's just nice to go up and
hear someone kind of say those things
the same way that
if you let's say me and you had a mutual
friend who's he's all right you know
not maybe a guy number four in the crew
and
so and everyone's coming up to you and
they're like this guy's the best all of
a sudden you find yourself in your head
like what and then everyone's telling
you that and then so that's making you
feel crazy but then when someone else
comes up like
hey he just had a really bad day so
we're just trying to get pump him up and
you go oh
yeah sure great guy yeah he's awesome i
just don't want to feel crazy
yeah yeah a lot of times you know when
just hearing someone push back against
these things is
enough to sort of you know because
sometimes you're in your workplace
you're like am i crazy
because you feel is every has everyone
lost their minds it starts to make you
feel crazy because you're being like
gaslit by society sometimes yeah is that
gaslighting i think
you know sometimes the right gets
knocked for being too
too blunt or you know they're they're
they're considered mean or impolite but
it's not that
we'd be happy to be polite it's just
don't
like relieve yourself on my leg and tell
me it's raining just let
me know what you're doing and that it's
not i'm not
completely out of my mind and we can go
along and be nice and all have a nice
civil society
yeah i think that everyone works a
little better when they're the
push i mean it's a weird scenario
because obviously the trump's in power
so you have
republicans in power but the liberals
clearly controlled thought and
everything everything else
yeah yeah so you have a it's kind of it
feels like for me like the whole woke
church
it's the reason why people are so
threatened is because they have their
bishop positions in that church
and then and they're saying you know
here's our list of things and
i'm kind of saying hey we have a bar
down the street where we're
we're all kind of partying and it's
really fun and everyone's leaving to go
hang out at that bar and they're like
just so you know we're gonna we're gonna
call you the worst things if you leave
because they if they know if you leave
it's a bishop position and they go yeah
that's the devil there and you go well
it's not really that we're just having
fun over here and they're like well you
can't
well if it hasn't happened already ryan
i'm pretty sure
that this conversation will get us both
excommunicated by the bishops
on me you're cursing me
i know well whatever though you can at
least go hang out at the bar and
the bar will be pretty fun down the
street uh we'll uh we'll leave it there
i've take taken up a ton of your time
but
i i do encourage everybody go
check out ryan longman his stuff is
really great
they can find you ryan on youtube they
can find you at your podcast the boys
cast with ryan long
where else myspace xanga live journal i
try to you know i try to root everything
to those two things you know i'm going
to be touring a lot and
it just comes back but youtube.com ryan
long comedy
instagram twitter uh tick tock parlor i
got them all
at ryan long comedy cool yeah i hit a
video every single monday morning at
uh 10 eastern standard time go check it
out
tennis i'm trying to figure out if that
conflicts with my show well if it does
right after my show then go out and
check out ryan's stuff
uh dude great great to talk to you keep
up the great work really funny stuff
and uh we'll have to have you back soon
i appreciate it dude i'll see you soon
[Music]
you